soy un 85 heterosexual
lo saben noche 25 90 por ciento y aún me
considero heterosexual y presenta
reunimos a siete mujeres heterosexuales
soy heterosexual soy hetero sexo soy
heterosexual soy heterosexual
heterosexual soy heterosexual soy
heterosexual
una de ellas miente si el grupo descubre
quién está mintiendo se repartieran el
dinero
si la mentirosa se queda ella ganará
todo el premio el impostor temporada dos
episodios siete diez mil
liz taylor no ha podido escuchar lo así
que diez pasan muchas cosas a la vez
todas ellas quieren hablar no dejan de
saltar intervenir y qué hacen en su
tiempo libre salgo a correr y tomó fotos
conmigo yo y trabajo cocino y viajo
mucho creo que mi esposo y yo hacemos
muchas cosas él es el último lugar al
que viajaron yo fui a japón dios bueno
encontramos a dónde fuiste quiero todo
tokio kamakura osa ganará ni crédito
no memorial predicciones de los
seguidores de jubilee en instagram solo
me dije voy a votar por la chica más
bonita que vea día poco tiempo unas
chicas intentaban hablar y ella estaba
algo callada
pensé que votarían por ellas y mejores
ya que yo
en serio trajeron que era yo que muy
bien en serio que estoy tan confundida
ahora no entiendo lo que sucedió en so
que la expulsaron porque todas estaban
celosas de que fuera tan bonita
levanten la mano si tienen alguna duda
puedo ver sus uñas no puedes tener las
uñas largas si eres lesbiana
no no no las mías quienes son del mismo
color y ruido no funciona porque todos
tenían uñas largas y bonitas
pero eso fue siempre eso fue ayer no
puedo hacerlo feliz cumpleaños
que hiciste no fui a un spa
fue genial no con jane fui sola bien
alguna
cuestionando su sexualidad seré sincera
hubo un momento en que yo pensé me
lavaron el cerebro para que me gusten
los hombres y cuando trata de mirar a
una chica dije no todos apreciamos a las
mujeres hermosas
claro que ya no podemos negarlo
[Música]
he salido con una mujer pero supongo que
si estuviera soltera y fuera el momento
no nuestra no lo sé quizás no en este
momento safi es 2021 y la gente es mucho
más abierta creo que la sexualidad es
como una especie de abanico quienes me
han atraído sexualmente han sido hombres
sí pero no por eso es imposible ya saben
que me siento atraída por una mujer
soy un 85% heterosexual soy un 85%
heterosexual eso fue una frase
interesante diciéndolo salen 85 o 90 por
ciento y aún me considero heterosexual
ya sabes y tú al final acabas resbalando
si no quieres ni haces nada pero las
cosas que ella dice son
a que trato de decir por qué no funciona
tu última relación fui a canadá y me
acosté con cuatro chicos si bien es un
dato de una semana de viaje mi ex más
reciente de hecho fuimos amigos 5 o 6
años y todo el tiempo pensé que era gay
así que cuando me dijo que yo le gustaba
en realidad yo hablaba con uno de sus
amigos fue como oye me siento algo
traicionado me gustas mucho y yo le dije
pero no eres que él
[Risas]
la chica con tu amiga vi me guiñó un ojo
como tú haz lo que hago y yo como esta
bien genial
adiós lucas adiós adiós antes de que yo
fuera la persona con más aspecto de la
típica lesbiana digo en mi bien confío
en ustedes creo que expulsamos al
impostor de no lo digo porque yo no
estoy tan seguro así en chicas
gracias mi dedo engordo y me lo quité
porque me cortaba la sirve de los 100
mira en la línea pronunciada lo del
matrimonio pero sin el anillo así que
pensaba de acuerdo tal vez y ella decía
para el bronceado y yo muy bien yo tengo
la de mi reloj donde conociste tu esposo
nos conocimos en la universidad él era
el mejor amigo de uno de mis vecinos y
el anillo y ella hablaba de su esposo y
pensé ella podría estar cambiando esposo
por esposo jose como se conoce conocimos
en un estudio hacemos músicos y así fue
la guitarra y yo guitarra y piano
también canto mientras él toca hacemos
jazz tocamos bodas todo el tiempo
hacemos versiones de jazz
por cierto si estás viendo te amo y
trabaja como oficial en el condado de
los ángeles no sé si quieren que
incluyamos eso era muy habladora y
siento que en ese sentido cuando alguien
intenta ocultar algo se vuelve más
hablador
la elegí porque su vida parecía tan
perfecto y maravillosa y creí que lo de
su marido podría ser una mentira
adiós chicas dios mío además y adiós
esta vez votarán para traer a alguien de
vuelta
hola bienvenido bienvenido no pueden
votar por mí y luego volver a expresarme
así que estoy muy bien
quien votó por ella porque galaxias jogo
deportivas antes cuando perdieron la
virginidad y yo a los 18 parejas gracias
mi mamá lo sabe se lo conté porque tuve
muchas pesadillas
era un lugar saben muy religioso y yo
teniendo yo no estaba casada así que si
es una de ustedes estaré muy sorprendida
fuerzas paramilitares como actrices son
increíbles
matt y fue algo extraña como confío en
ella pero no sé si deba
ajá
el experto en cerca del final y no
lograrlos levanten la mano si tienen
alguna duda y quieren continuar
si las luces se ponen verdes expulsaron
al mentiroso si las luces se vuelven
rojas el mentiroso sigue con ustedes y
perderán
y quién era la impostora puede dar un
paso adelante por favor
me di cuenta que era lesbiana a los 12
me juzgaron sin piedad toda la escuela
por ser gay
pasé por fases en las que me afeité la
cabeza y por las que me vestía muy
femenina sólo para descubrir quién era
cuando ella se mostró como la impostora
fue muy sorprendente no me lo esperaba
adivinaron mucho por la representación
de las lesbianas chicas yo los post y
todos los días sin exageración y ya te
ves increíble como si ya sabes no pues
es podría haber bajado el tono pero no
gracias a ver a chicas que realmente
creen que soy gay es genial porque no
tengo que dar explicación nuestros
premios si estamos en el 2021 y la gente
es mucho más abierta esperen que es esto
débil y vive intensamente